- I said, "Dad, I remember
when we were growing up
"you said, 'I moved to
America with $12 in my pocket
"'and I really wanted to, you know,
"'start a better life for everybody.'"
But I also know that I'm an actor
and I exaggerate everything.
'Cause that's literally--
- I don't know what you
are referring to, Kal.
(audience laughs)
- So, I called him and I said,
"I just want to make sure
I'm not exaggerating.
"You moved to America with
$12 in your pocket, right?"
And he, very understated, he goes,
"I'm afraid you are exaggerating.
"When I moved to America,
I had $8 in my pocket."
(audience laughs)
It's like (growls), man.
- That's like the version of,
"I went uphill in the snow."
- But the point is, yeah,
they worked incredibly hard.
- There must've been some
incredible challenges.
I can't even imagine that.
- There were a lot of challenges.
And I can tell you, they
did not move to America
for me to be an actor.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
Which I think was the
point of tell you that.
But, they're so supportive now.
I think part of it is,
for any parent really,
if you don't know that
that's an actual career.
In a lot of places around the world,
the arts are not a career,
there's not a commercial
sector for the arts.
It's scary, right?
You want your kids to have stability.
The arts are not stable.
Knock on wood and a
very fortunate few years
but you never know.
- You don't.
And it's like this.
- Yeah.
- At every level, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah, agreed, agreed.